Hallo hallo, ah ich sehe gerade, der neue Chat buggt, hups, warum ist jetzt auf einmal
Amazon auf, kek wait.
Der Chat buggt.
Sekunde.
Nur noch umstellen.
Small.
Badges.
Badges machen wir weg.
Das ist sonst zu viel.
Badges.
Ich muss gerade den Chat nochmal neu einstellen.
Animate Fade nach 20 Sekunden.
Ich chaste den neuen Chat.
Das neue Chat-Overlay gerade.
So, jetzt. Moment.
Moment.
Jetzt glaube ich noch besser.
Jetzt müsste es gehen.
Mach nochmal.
Guck mal, ob es funktioniert.
Also FFZ-Emotes müssten jetzt funktionieren.
Macht's.
Ja.
Gut.
Exzellent.
Ich hab doch nicht bis jetzt geschlafen.
So, jetzt lass doch mal kurz checken, dass FFZ-Emotes auch auf jeden Fall ordentlich funktionieren.
Ja, macht's.
Dentke.
Sehr schön.
Chat.
Jetzt haben wir einen ordentlichen Chat am Start.
Den kann man sogar ganz gut lesen,
weil er Shadows unterstützt.
Dentke.
Das ist ein geiles Emote.
manchmal fühlt man sich echt dente oder mal sehr zauberst weiter aber wir schwätzen erstmal eine
viertelstunde 20 minuten bis zum aufwärmen ich mache mal kurz package updates wenn wir gerade
dabei sind jawohl gibt es keine updates jawohl kölner updates heißt das wenn man keine updates
Ayaya.
Reboot.
Und wie findet ihr den neuen Chat?
Das neue Chat-Overlay.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut.
Man kann das gut...
Also erstens hat es
Better-Twitch-TV-Emotes,
FFZ-Emotes,
7TV-Modes.
Du brauchst die Shadows, dass du es besser erkennst, weil es transparent ist.
Wenn man das ohne Shadows, ich mach das mal ohne Shadows, warte mal.
Damit es dir auffällt, wenn man Shadows hier ausmacht.
Shadow, haben wir Shadow 0.
Pass mal auf.
So, und jetzt.
Frostchamp.
Guck.
Das sieht, das kann man jetzt nicht richtig erkennen.
Gerade, gerade, wenn der Hintergrund irgendwie wechselt oder ein bisschen heller ist oder so.
Halbtransparente Box geht glaube ich nicht.
Das kann das Ding nicht.
Da müssen wir das erste Mal ohne halbtransparente Box leben.
Also auf jeden Fall besser mit Shadow.
Ich habe jetzt das hier verwendet, um den neuen Chat zu generaten.
Ich habe vorhin auf Twitch gefunden.
Auf Reddit, auf dem Twitch-Reddit.
WTF.
Habe ich das gefunden.
Nennt sich JChat für Twitch.
Auf so einer super vertrauenswürdigen Seite, keine Ahnung.
Hintergrund kannst du direkt mit CSS
Stimmt, du hast recht
Du hast recht, du hast recht
Moment, Moment, Moment
Ähm, hab ich doch hier auch
Background-Color, guck mal, ich hab Background-Color
So, machen wir mal
Wie kann man 50% machen?
Checktest das dann?
50%?
Ist das valid CSS, wenn man 50% macht?
Okay, 0,5
Ist da jetzt irgendwas dahinter?
Ja, guck mal. Jetzt ist eine Box dahinter.
Schreibt mal was.
Chat-Community.
Jawoll.
Okay, so ist doch ganz gut, oder?
Wie findet ihr es besser?
Mit der halbtransparenten Box
oder ohne Box?
Und jetzt noch die Schatten aus.
Jetzt machen wir nochmal die Schatten aus
Und gucken nochmal wie das ist
Oh, hab ich's jetzt kaputt gemacht?
Ne
So ist gut, oder?
Ohne Schatten
Oder was meint ihr? Schatten oder keine Schatten bei der Schrift?
Ich find's ohne Schatten immer noch ein bisschen schwierig lesbar
Keine Schatten? Okay
Dann kein Schatten
Aber ich seh's hier gerade auf meinem
Vorschau, das kann man echt ganz gut lesen
Eigentlich vollkommen
Okay
So, jetzt haben wir auch ordentlich
Emote-Support wieder im Chat
Nachdem der BuzzStream Labs ja schon irgendwie
seit 2 Jahren oder so
kaputt ist
mit 7TV-Emotes
weniger fett ich glaube der platz ist ungefähr genau gleich wie vorher
identisch auch immer hauptsache hauptsache identisch
scheint zu funktionieren langer test
Wenn du jetzt natürlich so viel schreibst, dass es länger als die Chatbox ist, dann...
Aber das macht ja kaum einer.
Außer der Chainlaw ist wieder am Start und macht ASCII-Jab-Jab-Cock-Spam.
Der Chainlaw heißt ja gar nicht mehr so.
Der heißt ja irgendwie anders, weil sein Account gebannt wurde.
ich weiß nicht was er getrieben hatte
hoffe ich hoffe da ist noch manchmal am start
So.
Oh, ich bin nicht mehr eingeloggt jetzt bei Set-Servers.
Da müsst ihr weggucken jetzt gleich.
Leute, ich habe übrigens meine Projekt-Templates erweitert.
Ich habe jetzt Support für .NET, Go, Quarkus-Anwendung, Springbook-Anwendung und Rust.
Und .NET-Templates sind richtig pfeifert.
Da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, hier, cookiecutter-templates.net soll heißen, ja, Project Name, bester Name.
schon habe ich ein fertiges .NET Projekt. Und das Geile ist, dass ein .NET Projekt
mittlerweile genau aus einer Main-CS besteht, darf mittlerweile. Man braucht keine Project-Datei mehr.
Das ist eigentlich richtig nice. Das ist alles, was man braucht noch für ein komplettes .NET Projekt.
Und jetzt kann man das bilden tatsächlich. Zack. Gut, das liegt an der Arch-Installation von .NET,
die ist kaputt weiß nicht genau warum die kaputt ist aber wenn man das im container macht also wenn
ich hier ein container drin starte das ist wenn ich es bilde bilde ich das mit native
IoT ja starten wir das mal warum ich jetzt michel studio code gestartet habe
Moment, warum installiere ich überhaupt noch
Moment, Moment, ich muss mal kurz in meine Templates gucken
Ich war erst ein bisschen sidetracked, aber
.NET
Temp
Warum installiere ich denn noch Java überhaupt?
Warum installiere ich noch Java?
So, weil ich dumm bin.
Weil da noch Java drin stand.
Oh, ich für .NET Projekt nicht wirklich.
Aber das mache ich gleich wieder, weil das macht das Image auch super fett.
gleich geht's kommt a-m ruft aber vom projekt
studio weg geht push origin master massive passwort
sehr gut
Da sind wir am Start.
Guck, und jetzt kann ich direkt
mein .NET Projekt bilden,
was ohne Projektfiles
auskommt.
Geht einfach so.
Mittlerweile braucht man nur noch
eine Main-CS für .NET Projekt, seit der
letzten .NET Version. Das ist richtig nice.
Jetzt
kompiliert er das zu einem
Binary und dann
ist das auch lauffähig auf den letzten
paar jahren aller linux
net output da ist es man kann das natürlich belebig
unbedingt und sagt läuft meine dort net anwendung
Exzellent.
So.
Äh.
Wollte eigentlich ein Delete machen.
rm-rf
Project Name. Yes.
Gut.
Dann logge ich mich mal bei
Set Servers ein.
Da müsst ihr kurz
weggucken, Chat.
Ich nehme euch das Weggucken ab.
Ich muss mein Passwort gerade mal schnell tippen.
Das ist tatsächlich mal was anderes als 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Okay, so, da sind wir eingeloggt.
Zack.
Da sind wir wieder.
Szenarios, Leute, heute wird es schwierig.
Wir sind mit den Easy-Szenarien durch.
Jetzt gibt es nur noch Advancede und Schwere.
Ein paar haben wir da vorne ja schon gemacht.
Beinahe bin ich gefailt, weil ich auf den letzten Step nicht gekommen bin.
Aber so ist das halt.
Und jetzt kommen die medium schweren Dinger.
Da haben wir auch schon zwei Stück gemacht.
Die waren gar nicht so schwer.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Ich warte erst nochmal, bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist.
Ah hier, Lichtbringer, dankeschön.
Massive Subscription.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Ich habe übrigens die letzten Tage richtig viele Follows bekommen.
Was ich sehr nice finde.
Vielleicht lohnt es sich doch, längere Streams zu machen.
Exzellente Follows.
Das heißt, wer noch nicht gefollowt hat, kann jetzt gerne followen.
Und natürlich auch subscriben.
Aber wir sind, soll ich das mal ehrlich sagen,
wir sind mehr Follows fast lieber als mehr Subscriptions aktuell.
Ich mag das, wenn so die Zahlen so grüne Pfeile nach oben zeigen.
Gleich nochmal
ein Follower und so mag ich das.
Excellent.
Genau.
Stonks.
So mag ich das.
Du fändest mir am Montag
Stream cool. Da hab ich immer auf der
mal mit händen zu tun und kann nebenbei stream schon ja morgen mit java am start wahrscheinlich
ich kann euch das ja immer nicht zu hundertprozentig versprechen aber ich hab's vor ich habe ja montags
immer frei und da muss ich wieder arbeiten gehen ab dienstag monka es aller denn da werde ich erst
mal gar nichts checken wahrscheinlich ist auch mein passwort abgelaufen und alles braucht erst
mal zwei tage bis wieder alles funktioniert
wie viele meetings nächste woche ich habe noch nicht geguckt soll ich mal
gucken soll ich mal gucken ich guck mal was
mal. Ah, mein Arbeitshandy
hat sich neu gestartet.
Moment.
Sim entsperren.
Ich guck mal.
Nächste Woche.
Kalender.
Dienstag.
Daily Scrum.
9.30 Uhr.
Sprint Review.
Jetzt kann ich mir überlegen, wo ich hingehe.
Chat soll ich lieber zum Daily Scrum oder zum Sprint Review?
Ich glaube, ich gehe zuerst zum Daily Scrum und dann zum Sprint Review, weil das Daily Scrum geht bloß 15 Minuten und das Sprint Review geht eineinhalb Stunden.
Da komme ich einfach 15 Minuten später auf das Sprint Review, weil ich vorher beim Daily Scrum war.
Okay, also erstmal 9.30 Uhr, nochmal zwei parallele Termine.
Excellent.
So, 9.30 Uhr Daily Scrum, 9.30 Uhr eineinhalb Stunden Sprint Review.
dann um 10 Uhr, was sich auch überschneidet mit dem Sprint Review, Team Daily, 11 Uhr Sprint Retrospektive, dann ist es ja im Endeffekt schon 12.30 Uhr, dann gehe ich was futtern und dann ist 14.30 Uhr Sprint Planning für zwei Stunden.
das geht aber glücklicher meistens
glücklicherweise meistens nur eine Stunde oder so
das heißt im Endeffekt
so wirklich arbeiten kann ich morgen nicht
äh nicht morgen, am Dienstag
ich mein es ist von 9.30 Uhr
durchgehend bis
15.30 Uhr gemietet
das einzige wo mal kein Gemiete ist
ist ähm
so von
12.30 Uhr
bis 14.30 Uhr
Aber da bin ich auf jeden Fall mal
Mindestens eine halbe Stunde was futtern
Da hab ich bisschen Zeit was zu machen
Nach dem Mittagessen für eine Stunde oder so
Ansonsten hab ich an dem Tag nur Gemiete
Also eine Stunde kann ich Dienstags arbeiten
Excellent oder
Massive Meetings stellt
Ist es normal
Dass Sprint Review so lange dauert
Weiß ich nicht
Ist das normal
Chat, könnt ihr mir auch mal sagen, wie das bei euch ist?
Exzellent, ja.
Könnt ihr mir sagen, wie das bei euch ist? Also bei mir
ist das normal, dass das so
eineinhalb Stunden dauert.
Ich meine, dann kann ja jeder
was zu seinem Gedöns sagen.
Ja, und manche haben dann
den Hang dazu, natürlich das auch auszuweiten.
So nach dem Motto, ey, guck mal,
da gibt es jetzt ein neues Häkchen im Webinterface,
da halte ich jetzt erstmal eine halbe Stunde
Vortrag drüber.
Ist normal
Ja
Ist ein Sprint bei euch auch zwei Wochen
Das heißt ich habe jetzt mindestens zwei Sprints verpasst
Im Dezember
Wobei ich glaube die werden wahrscheinlich über Weihnachten und Neujahr
Das nicht
Wahrscheinlich haben die da keinen neuen mehr gestartet
Macht ja eigentlich keinen Sinn
Sprint
Ich muss mal kurz mich in meinem Home Assistant einloggen und meine Deckenbeleuchtung einschalten.
So, excellent. Die ist nämlich dimmbar.
Das muss ich jetzt anmachen und ein bisschen dunkler. So, ist gut.
Ja, wie gesagt, auch zwei Wochen.
Ja, das ist ordentlich.
Dann halten sie sich bei uns ja noch relativ zurück auch.
Wir sind weniger als 20 Personen. Wir dürften immer so um die 10 vielleicht sein.
Je nachdem wer da ist. Manchmal auch mehr, aber meistens um die 10.
Und wir kommen da meistens ganz gut durch.
Also das ist schon ganz okay, wie wir das machen.
Wir haben ja auch Sprint-Retrospektive und Sprint-Review.
Bei dem einen kann man quasi seine Arbeitssachen vorstellen, was man so getrieben hat und was da so schwierig dran war und was man jetzt tolles Neues hat und so.
Und bei dem anderen kann man sich darüber auslassen, was ein Problem im Sprint gemacht hat.
Also sich Kollege XY ist nie erreichbar, weil er für ein anderes Projekt arbeitet oder sowas.
Also, wir sind ja schon hyper agile hier.
Massive Agile.
Peter Agile.
Sind wir da.
Drei Stunden Cup.
Leute, zum Thema Cup kann ich auch was sagen.
In der alten Firma bin ich jahrelang als Vertreter von meinem Team aufs Cup gegangen.
Also wer das nicht kennt, muss man nicht kennen.
Müsst ihr euch keine Gedanken machen.
Ein Cup ist kein Taxi.
Das ist ein Change Advisory Board. Seid froh, wenn ihr das nicht kennt. Da bringt jeder relevante Änderungen mit und da werden die vorgestellt und da können andere Leute dann was zu sagen. So nach dem Motto, ah, aber die Telefonanlagenwartung nicht da und da machen und dann muss das da abgenickt werden.
Dass dann alle auch gesagt haben, okay, sie sind fein damit.
Da bin ich bestimmt zehn Jahre hingegangen als Vertreter für meine alte Arbeit.
Und da gehe ich lieber auf unsere Sprint-Retrospektive und Sprint-Reviews und Dailies und Scrums und Stand-Ups und was es nicht auch alles gibt, als Cap.
Cap war echt doof.
Am geilsten waren die Change Manager,
die keine Change managen wollten.
Auf der alten Arbeit.
Wart ihr auch schon mal in einem Cap?
Leute, in einem Change Advisory Board.
Gibt es dann meistens auch so nice Report
in irgendeinem Ticket Tool oder in irgendeinem
News Portal, so Changes der kommenden
Woche oder sowas.
Ja.
No Cap, ja das sagt man heutzutage
So, ich weiß aber nicht, was es bedeuten soll
Was bedeutet denn No Cap?
Hat nichts mit Kappa zu tun, oder?
Das bedeutet No Shit
Aha
Ohne Scheiß, quasi
Hier lerne ich noch Summersprache.
Wobei es gar nicht Summersprache ist.
Wie nennt man denn eigentlich Gen-Alphas?
Z- konnte man Summer sagen.
Rest ist alles, was älter ist als Generation.
Ist eh Boomer. Vollkommen egal, was.
Und wie nennt man Generation-Alpha-Leute?
Alpha-Alphas?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Gibt es dafür auch irgendeine
blöde, bescheuerte Bezeichnung?
Da gibt es doch bestimmt auch irgendwas
Jetzt Leute
Wenn ich so abwerten
Gegenüber der jungen Generation hier
Die müssen sich auch viel Scheiße auslöffeln
Diese Lost
Das ist aber auch
Leute Generation Alpha ist nicht
Die Fortnite Generation
Die Zuma Leute sind eher die
Fortnite Generation
Generation Alpha ist zu jung für Fortnite.
Gewesen.
Ich meine, vielleicht spielt der ein oder andere Fortnite.
Aber die spielen eher diese komischen Roblox-Minigames und sowas.
Ich habe irgendwo gelesen, das erfolgreichste Spiel 2024? 2025?
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
War irgendein Roblox-Mod, wo man seinen Garten gebaut hat.
Ich glaube 2024.
Ich glaube 2024 war das erfolgreichste Spiel überhaupt in Roblox Mod.
Ja, das kam bei uns auch vor, dass Changes abgelehnt wurden.
Das lag an unterschiedlichen Gründen, so nach dem Otto.
Die waren so schlecht beschrieben, dass keiner genau wusste, was es geht, was passiert.
oder aber es sind Sachen kaputt gegangen zu Zeiten, wo man nicht wollte, dass was kaputt...
Also es hatte meistens schon einen Grund, warum das abgelehnt wurde,
aber das hatten wir auch öfters, dass dann einer gesagt hat,
ja, aber das ist relevant für die Außenwirkung,
Außenwirkung war eh immer so das beste Wort schlechthin,
so nach dem Motto, das kriegen Leute mit, die quasi die Produkte benutzen,
Außenwirkung ganz schlimm und das müssen wir unbedingt jetzt sofort machen.
Aber solange die Managementleute dann auch die Verantwortung dafür übernehmen,
vollkommen okay wenn sie es natürlich danach wenn es kaputt gegangen ist nichts mehr von wissen
wollen, dann ist es kacke.
So.
Würde ich sagen, können wir anfangen.
So, also,
alle easy Szenarien sind durch.
Bis auf eins.
Das hier ist kein Szenario, das ist so ein
Szenario für Vorstellungsgespräche,
wo man drin rumwurschteln kann.
Das kann man nicht lösen in dem Sinn.
Das einzige, was wir nicht gemacht haben, ist SSL-Zertifikat.
Da habe ich auch wieder keinen Bock drauf.
Zertifikate sind mir ultra abfuck.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwo...
Oder sagen wir,
findet irgendjemand Zertifikate nicht abfuck?
Sagt er, bei uns läuft das so gut
und Zertifikatsmanagement so nice.
Das ist ganz toll.
Ich würde am liebsten am Tag 30 Zertifikate generieren.
Also bei mir daheim läuft das easy, automatisch mit Nginx Proxy Manager über Let's Encrypt.
Aber da gibt es ja auch nicht viel zu machen.
Ich habe ein Wildcard Zertifikat für alles fertig.
Aber Zertifikate sind fast immer Müll.
Zertifikate sind immer kompletter Krampf.
Ja, ich seh's schon.
Ich seh's schon. Ist nicht nur bei uns so.
Okay.
Dann würde ich sagen, fangen wir mal an.
Soll ich nochmal kurz sagen, was das hier eigentlich ist?
für alle die im letzten stream davon nicht dabei war also set servers ist eine seite mit glaub
mittlerweile an die 90 aufgaben bei jeder aufgabe kriegt man eine neue aws vm die kaputt ist und man
muss die fixen und am ende gibt es ein klopp wo man gucken kann ob man die richtig gefixt hat
Das ist quasi so eine Übungsplattform für angehende Linux-Admins oder für Linux-Admins, die gucken wollen, ob sie es können.
Oder für Vorstellungsgespräche oder einfach Leute, die sich dafür interessieren.
Das ist so ein bisschen Capture the Flag Lite, aber für Admin-Geschichten.
So, dann würde ich sagen, legen wir gleich los. Manhattan kommt heute dran. Szenario Manhattan. Can't write data into database. Hatten wir sowas nicht letztens erst? Wo das nicht richtig gemountet war?
Gibt es sowas auch für Windows Server?
Ne
Nicht, dass ich es gesehen hätte bisher
Aber Windows Server ist ja an sich schon problematisch
Also mein Beileid, ne
Ich habe immer mal wieder
Aber ehrlich gesagt
Einfach nur, weil ich ein bisschen
KekWen wollte.
Mal Windows Server angeguckt
und ich hab mir echt immer am Kopf greifen müssen,
wie man diesen Scheiß benutzen kann.
Das ist so
wir alles, ey.
Das ist
im Prinzip genauso wir wie Windows 11.
Nur als
Server-Version, ja.
Also irgendwie als nicht zusammenhängendes Zeug.
Das war ganz weird.
Vielleicht blickt man ja da durch, wenn man das ein paar Jahre gemacht hat.
Aber das ist so eklig, da will ich gar nicht durchblicken.
Kennst du die Windows-Leute bei dir auf der Arbeit?
Ja, klar.
Kenn ich die.
Max killt Windows-Server.
Zeig mal.
Moment.
Fuck.
Der geht in die Bounce rein.
Los.
Ja, man sollte halt kein M-RF an der falschen Stelle in WSL machen.
Dann ist der Server dead.
Guck, hier hatte ich noch einen Hintergrund.
Und zack ist der Hintergrund weg.
Alles dead.
Windows ist auch dead.
Verbot war's.
Hyper-V, MonkaS, Alter, ich muss ja Hyper-V hier benutzen in VMware Workstation mittlerweile,
weil ich die Windows Security Features nicht ausschalten will.
Das nervt mich jetzt schon.
Also ich muss glücklicherweise kein Windows benutzen auf der Arbeit.
Also ich muss Windows auf dem Notebook benutzen, ja, okay.
Benutze das quasi als Frontend für meine Linux-VM.
aber also windows server herr bloß auf
da lasse ich die finger von da habe ich auch keine ahnung also ich lasse aus
mehreren gründen die finger davon erstens weil ich keine ahnung habe und
zweitens weil ich keine ahnung davon haben weil ich so eklig finde hast du
wsl2 oder wie kannst du darfst du linux nutzen
du meinst auf der arbeit ich habe eine linux vm und von dort xv wurde ich mir
einfach mal rüber auf die windows kiste weiterer grund warum ich das kritisch
sehe wenn immer mal land kommt
dann muss ich mit irgendwie sowas wie die vnc oder xrdp oder oder gibt gibt
es gibt es weil rdp eigentlich weil rdp server
Wie bekomme ich einen Server unter...
Oh, das ist wieder...
Kack-Reddit-Übersetzung.
Kann man das irgendwie ausschalten eigentlich?
Okay, anscheinend gibt es sowas.
Aber wahrscheinlich funzt das auch nicht richtig.
Könnte werden, es funzt nicht richtig.
Unterweiland.
Lieber nachts alleine durchs Bahnhofsviertel
oder Windows Admin sein? Lieber alleine durchs Bahnhofsviertel.
Max, denkst du,
morgen werden die Sturm... Boah, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich mir keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Also wie gesagt, ich x4 wurde mir beispielsweise Terminator, so so, das ist eine grafische
Konsole unter Linux, weil Westterm nicht richtig funktioniert über x4 oder zu lahm ist.
Und dann mache ich alles da drin.
Und wenn ich eine GUI Anwendung brauche, wie Wireshark zum Beispiel, wird die einfach auch über X4Ding rüber gemirrored.
So, auf geht's, run, bam.
Also
Szenario Manhattan
Description
Oh oh oh oh
Moment Leute
Da ich das jetzt wieder leake
Ich muss ja
Meine Leiste verstecken
Hier oben
Mal gucken wie gut
Mal kurz
Wollen wir mal gucken wie gut die Translation
Fähigkeiten sind von
GLM 4.7
Übersetze
Das auf Deutsch
Gucken wir mal
Na geht doch eigentlich.
Aber DeepL ist wahrscheinlich immer noch besser, was Übersetzung angeht.
Ihr Ziel ist es, eine Zeile in eine vorhandene Postgres-Datenbank einzufügen.
Das Problem ist nicht spezifisch für Postgres, Sie müssen keine Details darüber kennen, obwohl es helfen kann.
Nützliche Postgres-Gelb.
Es handelt sich um ein Dienst, der auf...
Moment.
Kommt das aus der Beschreibung? Ja.
dienste auf port 5 432 lauscht und auf festplatte in ein daten da die
übersetzung ist nicht so gut er datenverzeichnis schreibt der speicher
und dieses verzeichnis im parameter data direkt der konfigurationsdatei postgres
konnte mir in diesem post ist ja so okay also im prinzip geht es darum dass wir
den befehl hier ausführen können sollen
und
Und das soll funktionieren.
Postgres Not Running.
Geht schon gut los.
Das hatte ich schon.
Hier kommt mir auch so vor, aber...
Aber hatte ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht.
Hier, guck mal, es ist kein Solved.
Es gab anscheinend ein sehr ähnliches Szenario.
Wir hatten eins bei schwer, glaube ich, was so ähnlich war.
Android, äh, guck hier, Hongkong hatten wir
Das war die schwere Variante von dem
Okay, also gucken wir mal
Systemctl, Status
Post
Och, wir haben
Wir haben kein Auto complete
Oh, Postgres
Läuft
Lauscht aber nicht
gucken wir mal ob sich die starten lässt ok post selbst scheint zu laufen netz
5 432 lauscht nix da gucken wir doch mal in die loks rein würde ich sagen also post
meckert gar nicht großartig also die haben scheint alles ohne probleme zu starten war
lockt rups war lockt postgres lockt da mal rein was es da so gibt hier gibt es ein lockt aus
ql und lockt not create lock file post master pitt no space left on device
die festplatte ist voll opt pg data opt pg ich kann echt nicht im opt pg data
War Logbeste.
Journalctl rumgefrickelt da.
Benutze auch Netzstat noch.
Und ifconfig.
Ach guck mal, hier kann man Sachen löschen.
Delete me.
File backup.
Naja, dann würde ich sagen,
wir löschen einfach auch mal die Backups mit.
Braucht eh keiner.
Wer braucht schon Backups?
Das hatten wir noch nicht
Wir hatten was ähnliches
Das ist die einfache Variante von dem, was wir schon gemacht haben
Restart
Aha, jetzt hat es auch länger gedauert
Jetzt lauscht er auch
Und jetzt
Insert, jawohl, wir haben es geschafft
Problem war, die Festplatte war voll.
Easy.
Geschafft.
Naja, wenn du gar keine Ahnung von Linux hast
und nie das Problem hattest, dann brauchst du dafür auch eine Weile.
Szenarios
So, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Tokio
Can't surf web file
Hatten wir Tokio nicht schon?
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor
Aber anscheinend
Anscheinend nicht
There is a web server
Surfing a file
Moment, hatten wir das vielleicht?
Ne, das hatten wir
Der erste Webserver serving a file.
War wie...
With contents Hello Setter.
But when we try to check it locally...
Gibt nichts zurück.
Okay.
Und dann, auf geht's.
Open
Also dann überprüfen wir das erstmal
Das kann ich euch generell bei Problemen auch immer empfehlen
Überprüft erstmal ob ihr das Problem nachstellen könnt
Aha, ok
403 verbinden
You don't have permissions to access this resource
Aha
Das ist bestimmt ein Problem
War www.html oder irgendwie sowas
Dann gucken wir doch mal
Kurz, als welcher User
Achso, wir wissen, es muss gar kein
Nginx sein, okay
Als welcher User das Ganze
Läuft
also html guck mal ob wir die richtigen die richtigen rechte hat ja das sieht okay aus
was läuft da jetzt läuft auf port 80 apache aha
der läuft als welcher user www data gut dann würde ich sagen wir werden wir mal www data
und gehen wir nach war www html hat index hier ist das problem da sieht man es doch
schon. LQS,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Excellent Subscription.
Das hier
sieht man doch schon als Problem.
Nur Root hat Lese- und Schreibrechte.
Alle anderen nicht. Und
wwwData braucht die Rechte.
CD,
HTML,
chown, wwwData,
chown,
wwwData,
wobei, ganz ehrlich, chmod777,
Keck, weh.
Kunst, easy.
Gelöst.
Das ist easy. Das ist einfacher als die einfachen Aufgaben gewesen teilweise.
Fertig.
Ups.
Check my solution.
Was?
Wie inkorrekt.
Kunst doch.
Warte mal.
Curl.
2,7.
Ah, Moment.
Wir haben noch mehr Probleme.
Wir haben noch mehr Probleme, Leute.
1,2,7,0,0,1.
Das Zertifikatszenario.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf Zertifikate.
Das ist bestimmt IP Tables gedöhnt, hä?
Das ist bestimmt IP Tables.
War mal ein bisschen größer.
Das ist bestimmt hier IP Tables.
Minus V, minus L.
Nö.
Ach, Job, hier, guck mal.
Ja, das ist es.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie man IP Tables Regeln löscht.
IP Tables List?
Ne, ach keine Ahnung.
How to delete IP Table Rules.
IP Tables minus S.
Ah ja, genau, genau jetzt, ja, oder auch nicht.
In welcher Chain ist denn das überhaupt? Chain Input.
Und wie macht man das jetzt hier?
Kann ich jetzt sowas sagen wie D, wobei F Input muss tatsächlich auch funktionieren.
Das flasht ja alle Regeln da.
Ja.
Chatge.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es gelöst.
Korrekt.
Zack.
Jetzt geht es aber Schlag auf Schlag.
Docker Container won't start.
Ja, ich habe mich verklickt.
Mit dem Clou.
Docker-Container won't start.
Also, dann gucken wir mal, warum der won't startet.
Description.
Dockerize Node.js Web-Application.
Home Admin App Directory.
Create a Docker-Container, so you get a Web-App on port 8888 and can curl to it.
For the solution to be valid, there should be only one running Docker-Container.
Okay, da schauen wir mal, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Docker-Stelz.
Eine Node.js-Anwendung.
Ja, auf.
Wenn du alle mit voller Punktzahl und ohne Hilfe löst, kriegst du ein 32 GB RAM-Kit.
Das wäre sicherlich ein riesen Boost für die Seite, ja.
wenn sie so was hätten löse alles fehlerfrei gewinne 32 gb ram kit
also docker stellt unter
ist das docker file
ok docker bild doch er läuft schon einmal nicht geht schon geht schon gut los ok permission die
night main user ist nicht nicht in der docker group na gut wir können auch durchaus das mal
als gut funktioniert dann machen wir das doch als gut juckt mich doch nicht atmen
wir könnten auch das dem der docker gruppe hinzufügen aber drauf wurscht ok also bilden
funktioniert schon mal
von dem Container.
Das funzt.
Also docker run
minus minus it minus minus
äh ne warte mal, es ist minus it nur, ne?
Minus minus rm
oder? Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Genau, minus it
und minus minus rm.
Hecke.
Aha.
User
Serve Module Not Found.
Das ist irgendein
Keck.
JavaScript Error. Das hat doch mit Docker wahrscheinlich
nichts zu tun, ne?
Kann man da rein exec'en?
Äh.
Warte mal.
Das habe ich auch richtig gemacht, oder?
Da ist wahrscheinlich einfach keine Shell drin.
Ach, ich muss den Entry Point überschreiben.
Gut, also das
funzt nicht. Da ist bestimmt
irgendwas verkehrt beim Container
bauen. Gucken wir mal in das
Docker-File rein.
Also.
Create App Directory. Copy
Files.
Copy Package
Sternchen
JSON nach
NPM
Install
Okay, Port ist schon mal falsch
Es soll Port 888 sein
Aber das ist nicht das Problem
Also ich sehe jetzt hier auf den ersten Blick
Schon mal nix
Ist da Node drauf?
Wie heißt das?
Node.js Packaging.
Installieren ist jetzt einfach.
Oh, nee.
Geht nicht.
Ah, vielleicht ist was im Docker
Ignore drin, sodass es da nicht rüber kopiert.
Nee, Node Modules NPM Debug.
Äh, warum geht denn das nicht?
Wir starten das jetzt einfach mal von Hand.
Ganz ohne Docker-Container.
Node.js
Server.js
cannot fach so ja klar weil ich npm npm install nicht gemacht habe
install npm erstmals halbe internet runterladen auf die vm
Boah
Gleich ist die VM voll
So viel Speicher hat die doch bestimmt gar nicht
Alter, was installiert der alles für NPM?
GCC?
Was?
C++ Compiler?
Halme Knorm Umgebung?
Warum braucht das NPM?
Warum braucht es NPF?
GTK?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
JavaScript.
Keck JavaScript.
Was anderes kann ich da nicht zu sagen.
Eigentlich
ist das total dumm,
was ich mache.
das System versauen mit NPM und Node.
Ich sollte einfach einen zweiten Docker-Container starten,
irgendeinen Debian-Trixi-Docker-Container.
Und das mounten und darin ausprobieren.
Weil dann wäre das auch wieder weg.
Das machen wir gleich optional,
weil jetzt zeige ich euch, wie man es nicht macht, okay?
So macht man es nicht.
Man versaut sich nicht sein System mit 30 Milliarden Packages.
so drei stunden später npm install wahrscheinlich haben wir jetzt gleich
frei holt oder irgendwie sowas drauf und 30 cv abilities ach wurscht
ist port 88 address in use
Da läuft ein Nginx auf dem Server
Aha
System CTL
Disable
Nginx
Gibt es sowas wie Stop oder sowas da auch noch?
Ne
Stop
minus minus now gilt auch bei disable aha
ich wollte ich weiß dass es stop gibt ich meinte ob es nicht was gibt wie man das in
einem befehl machen kann so jetzt läuft das nicht mehr und jetzt gucken wir ob die no js
ok jetzt startet der no js die deutsche geschichte wir wissen aber immer noch nicht
das hat das docker was hat das muslims am docker fall liegen
der fuck aller moment ist es ist es das ja das heißt server js
server js
locker bild
das ist aber viel sowas zu sehen
was
und das ist peisen stellt ok
Run.
Läuft.
Wir müssen jetzt nur noch Ports weiterleiten.
Äh, hallo?
Oh.
Äh.
Leute, wir haben ein Problem.
Kann das nicht mehr abbrechen?
Check my solution?
Nee, shit.
Ging nicht.
Äh.
Dann machen wir das mal wieder kurz zu.
Open in Terminal.
Ich hätte das in der Tmux Session starten sollen.
Upt Install Tmux.
Braucht man eh auf jedem Server.
Docker ps.
Das läuft noch.
Docker stop.
mal aus und dann starten wir das in der thema session
auf docker machen
also docker minus m
äh, Run.
Falsch rum, das Run muss davor.
Docker, Run.
Okay, das funzt.
Docker, Stop.
Zack.
Jetzt müssen wir noch die Ports exposen.
Also minus P.
minus p 8888 nach 8888 sagt jetzt köln haus 8888 bernhard da sind wir alles klar habe geschafft
er kann man modus aktiviert easy easy
easy clap
so was haben wir jetzt wenn es da habe ich nicht noch irgendwie so
ein doofes im mond von battlefield
kann man nie anbringen aber jetzt passt
wenn es m1 in a container try and figure out if you are inside a container like a docker
one for example inside the virtual machine like in the other scenarios ok mac adresse
vom interface nachgucken ist jetzt meine erste meine erste an links bums
danach wird wort wird wort meinst du meinst
wollte er nicht noch zeigen wie man die so wie man es richtig macht das habe ich vergessen
gestern gedacht richtiger wäre es gewesen ein beispielsweise debian container zu starten sich
das da rein zu mountain und dort node.js zu installieren und ein bisschen rum zu
basteln anstatt auf dem system ist es sich das system zu versauen
Ja, auf ist der Server jetzt bald einmal da.
Hopp, hopp, hopp.
Was macht denn der Amazon wieder, dass das so lange dauert?
Oder liegt es an Vodafone?
Aber an Vodafone kann es jetzt schlecht liegen, dass bei AWS der Server nicht aufbaut.
Ja Chat, was machen wir, wenn der Server nicht aufbaut?
Dann sagen wir, refreshen wir die Seite.
Ich refreshe mal.
You all have a running instance
Ich hab keine running instance
Sieht man auch hier
Kein Server runnt
Hat das grad Probleme
Ich hab kein Server
Running server
Ich glaube es ist kaputt gerade
Ach jetzt
Okay
Destroy
Nochmal
Run
Ich lasse jetzt einfach die Finger weg
Auch wenn es 5 Minuten dauert
Genau um die Server fixen zu können
müssen wir erstmal die eigentliche Seite fixen.
die zertifikate übung mache ich nicht auch wenn die easy ist ich habe kein bürger auf zertifikate
kannst du bitte erklären was du gerade machst nichts ich warte bis ein server aufgebaut ist
das hier ist eine seite da kann man üben kann man seine linux skills üben da gibt es um die
weil sie die 80 90 aufgaben bei jeder aufgabe kriegt man eine neue einen neuen
server bei aws der kaputt ist und eine beschreibung was denn an dem server
kaputt ist und dann muss man den server wieder ganz machen und wenn den server
wieder ganz gemacht hat gibt so knopf zu überprüfe ob jetzt alles stimmt oder
kriegst du hier ein häkchen wenn es geschafft hast jetzt haben wir es da ist
also let's go größer sagt also was ist jetzt noch mal das problem wir sollen rausfinden
ob wir innerhalb von einem container sind wir gucken uns erst mal die mac adresse an
was ist das für eine mac adresse
Gibt's da irgendwas zu?
Warte mal, warte mal.
Ich hab mich ver...
Alter.
Ich hab schon gedacht,
es sieht verdächtig nach einer IPv6-Adresse aus.
Aber...
Not found.
Geil, die AI ist wieder geil hier.
Beginnt mit dem Briefing, das zu einer Organisation gehört, die sich mit Netzwerk- und Sicherheitslösungen bescheidet.
Geilerweise Bescheide.
Okay, das ist schon mal keine standardmäßig bekannte...
Wir sind eine VM.
Okay, dann...
Upt, Update.
Upt, Install.
Wirt, What.
Das ist das Einfachste, was mir so einfällt.
Wir sind in einem Container.
Auf einer KVM-VM.
In AWS.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ich hab dieses Tool noch nie mehr als eine Sache ausgeben sehen.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Wir können gucken, ob es ein Dev...
DevKVM gibt es nicht.
Wir können gucken, ob es ein Prog...
Oh, wie ist das...
Moment, wie war das nochmal bei Containern?
Container Progself?
Progself?
Ist das dann automatisch ein Container?
Ne.
Da konnte man das irgendwie feststellen.
Ähm.
Seacroops?
Also ich würde sagen, wir laufen in einem Container.
wir können übrigens noch was ausprobieren der ultimative test pass mal auf das ist voll durch
die brust ins auge aber der ist easy und zwar wir können sagen mod proben nicht drauf installiert
modprobe.
Fabian install
modprobe. Wir unloaden
Kernelmodule. Wenn das geht, sind wir in der VM.
Kmod.
Mod.
ModProbe-RPCSpeaker.
Achso.
Not found in directory.
Ich habe jetzt gedacht,
wir unloaden einfach mal ein Kernelmodul.
Und wenn das geht, sind wir auf jeden Fall
in einer VM.
ModProbeTestModule.
Gibt es so ein Testmodul dafür?
LS-Mod.
Können wir gucken, was geladen ist.
FAT.
VFAT ist geladen.
Mod Pro minus R VFAT.
VFAT.
Aber
müsste das nicht einen Fehler geben,
wenn man das im Container macht?
Was passiert? Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Was passiert?
Docker Run.
Wenn man in einem Container einen Mod-Probe macht.
Und da irgendwas hinzufügt oder so.
Upt, Install, K-Mod.
Das ist jetzt ein lokaler Container bei mir.
Mod-Probe-R-PC-Speaker.
Not found, LS-Mod.
Aufhört.
CD-ROM, ja, das brauchen wir nicht.
CD-ROM not found.
Okay, da kommt immer not found anscheinend.
Not found, not found, not found.
Also...
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass man unter
Brock
die Prozessdinger
sehen kann.
Seacroops?
Da gab es was ganz einfaches.
Das habe ich sogar letztens in Go gebraucht.
Proc-Command-Line ist auch eine gute Idee.
Aber das könnte durchaus sein, dass man das im Container auch sieht.
Also normalerweise verlasse ich mich hier drauf.
Wird what?
was bedeutet diese ausgabe das system läuft in einem lxc container kvm das system hat zugriff
auf kvm das system erkennt dass es in der infrastruktur von aws läuft okay ja also
Ich würde auch sagen, es läuft in einem Container.
Aber es gibt bestimmt hier die Möglichkeit...
Get-Container-ID-Inside-Container.
Es gab so...
Das habe ich, als ich diese RAM-Sachen ausgelesen habe.
Hier Major Falls und sonst was.
Da gab es...
Brock...
Pits?
Ne, wo...
Ja.
Aber dass man hier mehr als eine Pit sieht, spricht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Proc self cgroup.
Okay, das ist ein Container dann.
Cut.
Proc self.
Sieg sie.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist dann...
Daran konnte man das irgendwie erkennen.
Ne, das ist kein Container.
Ne, daran kann man das nicht erkennen.
Prog.
Sieht bei mir genauso aus.
Was ist noch ein guter Weg, um es zu erkennen, dass man in einem Container ist?
Wollen wir mal die AI fragen?
Das muss nicht so sein.
Proc self-mount info.
Warte mal, falsch.
Das ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt verdächtig viel, ja?
ok best way to best way to check if i'm inside and linux container slash container das ist das
das könnte genauso gut vom haus sein system detect wird so was gibt es so was gibt es
gibt es wirklich habe ich nie gehört
container aber all das system die hat ja alles mittlerweile
okay wir sind auf jeden fall in dem container wird wort sagt wir sind in
einem container system detect wird sagt wir sind in einem container was gibt's
für dinge filebase checks manuell check for the extent oft der das das muss nicht so sein das
muss ja nicht unbedingt in in docker laufen das muss ich unbedingt in docker laufen konnte check
Proc 1 C Group in a Container.
Genau, das habe ich gesucht.
Cut
Proc 1 C Group
in its scope.
Äh, das
äh.
Wie sieht denn das bei mir im Docker Container?
Cut
Proc
Steht gar nichts drin.
Das ist Blödsinn, was sich das ausgedacht hat.
Check
Environment Variablen.
Naja, das muss auch nicht so sein.
Das muss auch nicht so sein.
Da sieht man jetzt auch nichts.
Also, ich verlasse mich auf die Ausgabe der Tools.
Ich sage, wir sind in einem Container.
Es ist Blödsinn hier.
Also ich sage, wir sind in einem Container.
Ich habe noch eine Idee.
Wir installieren einfach Docker und gucken, ob was läuft.
Weil für Docker...
In Docker musst du ja normalerweise den Docker-Socket weiterleiten.
Aha.
Ist das Docker?
Fuck, Docker funktioniert.
Ach gut, in einem LXC-Container, wo das...
Wo das...
Weiterhin erlaubt ist, kann das schon sein.
Ich sage aber trotzdem, wir sind in einem Container.
Wir sind in einem Container.
Chat, habt ihr noch irgendwelche Ideen?
Wir haben zwei Tools, die sagen, man ist in einem Container.
Ich vertraue da jetzt einfach mal drauf.
Welchen Vendor?
Du meinst von der MAC-Adresse?
Das war ziemlich nichtssagend.
Wir konnten mit Modprobe nichts unloaden.
Das war auch schon mal.
Ja, also Modprobe funzt einfach nicht.
Ja, also wir können...
Das schmeißt einfach...
Es geht einfach nicht, das zu unloaden.
Das ist schon mal irgendwie verdächtig, dass man keine Kernel-Module loaden und unloaden kann.
Jetzt sag ich doch Hardware-Vendor.
Hier von der Netzwerkkarte kannst du gucken.
Und da kommt aber nichts bei raus.
Das könnte aber auch eine VM sein.
Mit der Custom Mac dann.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin mir relativ sicher, wir sind im Container.
Gibt es da eine Auflösung zu?
Check my solution
Not implemented
Okay, dann gucken wir uns die Clues an
Und schauen mal
Ob wir aufs Richtige gekommen sind
Der hat auch Clues
Das ist in fact
Der Portman Container
Okay Leute
Wir haben recht, es ist ein Container
Environment of the Pit 1 Process
Aha
Okay, da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen
Container
Aha
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen
Ähm
Aber wir haben mit Weird What und diesem System D Ding
Haben es ja auch rausgekriegt
Okay, Container.
Destroy Server.
Zack.
Next.
Close and open file.
Was ist das?
The file is open
for writing by some process.
Close this file without killing the process.
Oh, da muss ich irgendein Signal schicken wahrscheinlich.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Dual mit dem Krieger.
Habe ich ganz wenig, also was heißt ganz wenig, gar keinen Kontakt mehr die letzten Jahre gehabt.
Wüsste ich auch gar nicht, über was wir groß reden sollen.
Der spielt gerade WoW, habe ich gesehen.
Sauerkraut.
War er ziemlich lahm?
Ist er schon gestorben?
Oder immer noch sein erster Char?
Ich mach wieder Youtube Videos, ja aber ich weiß noch nicht wann.
Also ich hab nicht vor für immer keine Videos zu machen.
Aktuell bin ich noch bei Claire Obscure.
Sonst hast du ja Französisch aussprechen dabei.
So.
Also dann zeige ich mal hier.
Es gibt some file.
Gibt es gar nicht.
Achso, wir sind gar nicht hier.
Some file gibt es hier.
Read, write.
Nur vom Admin.
ok gleich mal hier den ok es sind keine war das nicht war acl zwar das nicht
get get fuck fuck fuck irgendwie so unter linux war sich get get fuck
klingt jetzt bisschen komisch aber jetzt fackel okay gibt sie also acl
geschichten können es nicht sein läuft beruflich habe vor zwei jahren oder
zweieinhalb jahren oder so weiß gar nicht wann der arbeitgeber gewächst bin
ich sehr happy drüber auch immer noch okay tailwindsappsumfile hier
Hier wartet angeblich irgendwas rein.
Äh, ich sehe da nichts
warten, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Was ist denn hier?
Open File.sh
Der, der
Ridet auf
Stream 66
Hier
Bash
LSOffReturnsNothing?
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Achso, das ist der Test.
LSOffReturnsNothing.
Achso.
Close this file without killing the process.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Ich muss den Scheiß mal auch ordentlich lesen.
Hier.
383.
Das hier.
Das ist der Bash-Prozess,
der darauf zugreift.
Und jetzt einfach Bash killen darf ich nicht.
Wie lief deine Reha? Habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Hat noch keinen Tod,
aber ein Close Call-Moment.
Das muss ich mal reingucken.
Kurz Zeitracken lassen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Jetzt hat er genau hier oben
über Zeug drüber.
Ach ne, das ist das Overlayer.
Oh, oh.
10%.
Oh.
Das war knapp.
Was spielt denn ein Hunter?
Ja, ne?
Hunter, würde ich sagen.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Hunter haben mich immer übelst abgefuckt.
Als ich
Priest of Classic gespielt habe.
Weil die alles irgendwie
mit ihrem Pet immer so dumm gepullt haben.
Beste Gruppe war immer noch.
Drei Mages
und AE-Farm.
Oder vier Mages,
AE-Farm.
So, also.
Wo sind meine entstehen geblieben?
Ja, beste.
ich level ich also ich level in total gern einfach über dungeons und das soll natürlich
auch noch halbwegs schnell gehen und das war ein classic das besser was mir meist spaß gemacht hat
war so mage gruppen farmen priester rest mages so weil dann auch schon klitschen muss teilweise
Also Treppe hochrennen, Treppe runterrennen, dass die Mobs umdrehen und sowas.
Das hat Spaß gemacht.
So, aber jetzt mal hier weiter.
Also, wir sollen nicht den Prozess killen.
Also der Prozess greift auf das Pfeil zu.
Wir sollen nicht den Prozess killen, der auf das Pfeil zugreift.
Wir können mit Kill irgendein Signal schicken.
Oder Truncate oder irgendwie sowas machen.
Geht das vielleicht?
Da gab es doch irgendwann Kill, Signal, irgendwie sowas.
list of kill signals
linux signal
close file
was setzt ihr aber hin?
das ist eine seite
guck
das ist eine seite wo du 90 szenarien hast mit kaputten und mit kaputten servern das heißt so
und ich selber sind halt weil sie kaputt sind so du kriegst bei jedem szenario eine beschreibung
des fehlers hier zum beispiel ja und hast dann am ende so ein knopf ob überprüfe meine lösung
ob das stimmt was ich gemacht habe als dein job ist es quasi den fehler auf dem server zu beheben
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich den Bash-Prozess kille?
Der wird bestimmt nochmal neu gestartet, automatisch, oder?
Oder muss ich das Szenario neu starten, wenn ich den Bash...
Ah!
Man kann den gar nicht so ohne weiteres...
Pass auf!
Kill minus 9, bam!
Oh, dann stoppt der ganze Server!
Okay, der wollte vorbeugen, dass man das nicht cheesen kann.
Okay, der hat vorgebeugt.
Hä?
Der hat vorgebeugt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir 9-1-2.
Moment, ist das meine Bash?
Ist das meine Bash, die das öffnet?
Warte mal, Bash RC?
Da muss der erstmal drauf kommen.
Da musst du erstmal drauf kommen.
Okay, Bash RC.
So.
So, jetzt läuft nichts mehr.
Ich muss das einfach nur aus meiner
Basher-C rausschmeißen.
Und die Session-Neustart.
Ey, da musst du erst mal drauf kommen.
Das ist jetzt ja wirklich fies gewesen.
Wollen wir uns mal die Clues angucken?
Was manche der Browser-Terminals haben,
ein Shortcut, um dein Terminal vorwarnen zu können.
Wie meinst du das?
Also Windows-Taste plus F macht bei mir das Fenster in Fullscreen.
Gucken wir uns die Clues an.
Also wir haben es jetzt ja geschafft.
LS off zeigt nichts.
Next clue.
Solution.
Find the file descriptor haben wir gemacht.
Use the exec build in bash command.
Haben wir nicht gemacht.
Aha, das hätte man auch machen können.
Leute, wir haben es komplett anders gefixt.
Wir haben es aus der Basher C geschmissen.
Also wir haben nicht die...
Wir haben nicht die Route verfolgt, die eigentlich gewollt war.
Wo willst du an die Uhr kommen?
Hier, bam.
Aber Server ist jetzt weg.
Okay, wir haben es nicht richtig gemacht, aber wir haben es hingekriegt, dass das was zählt.
Was haben wir hier als nächstes? Melbourne, wie, oh, das klingt, das ist, ist das eine Ruby?
Ne, das ist eine Python-Anwende, oder?
Gunicorn, Python-HTTP-Server, Python.
Okay, run.
also es gibt ein peisen wie es die web application darunter der purpose of which
is to serve the string hello world dass die anwendung die brauner unbedingt gibt
die gibt es auch nie gab es noch nie vorher okay feile service server
which is fronted by an engine x server all servers managed by systemd so the flow of the
http request is web client engine x goonie corn ratings vsg python the objective is to be able
to call the local host and get back hello world ok na dann gucke mal
war der letzten war bei der letzten noch ein anderer besser was erlaufen der das geschrieben
hat oder hätte check solution von anfang an funktioniert wenn du dich nie einloggen das
ist eine gute das ist eine sehr gute frage wenn ich mich nicht einloggen und check solution drücke
könnte sein dass es funktioniert ja das probiere erinnere mich gleich noch mal dran das probieren
gleich noch mal aus wenn wir das hier fertig haben
also was haben wir jetzt hier bs aus letztes minus tulpen und sie kleiner
oder mama bis hier kann es vielleicht eins größer machen kann man nicht also
was haben wir hier wir haben einen server laufen auf weder auf 80 wir haben server laufen auf 18
was anderes also ich sehe hier schon mal nichts laufen gerade oder auf 80 ich sehe jetzt da nichts
laufen also system ctl system ctl status wie es das ding unicorn service active
das listen auf einem socket ok unix run unicorn sock ich habe ich habe das noch nie im leben
benutzt und was macht unser nx steuerung wie geht es wieder los status steuerung
wie löscht nämlich normalerweise in der schellenden wort aber im browser schließt das fenster
nx
ach der läuft mich okay der startet bestimmt auch nicht doch machte der startet okay
jetzt minus tulpen wir haben ein wir haben kein engine x laufen und nix auf port 80 doch jetzt
da ein bisschen gebraucht köln localhost gateway ok der nx ist nicht richtig konfiguriert
der nx richtig konfiguriert der leiter nicht richtig auf den unicorn weiter
ok also schauen wir mal engine x config
sites enabled dürfte nichts drin sein default ach hier guck mal listen port 80 location
include proxy params,
was auch immer, proxy pass.
Jetzt die Frage,
wie macht man, Moment, Moment, Moment,
Http Doppelpunkt,
das stimmt doch so schon mal nicht, oder?
Warte mal.
Nginx proxy Unix
Socket.
Oder doch?
Macht man das doch so?
Vielleicht ist das eine falsche Berechtigung.
Könnte auch sein.
Ist das hier korrekt?
Das weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf, wie die Nginx-Config sein muss.
Maus gleich.
Copy.
Ist es korrekt?
Syntax.
Fragen wir einfach mal.
er ist ein lux korrekt syntaktisch das ist es denn als nächstes konfiguriert
boxen request aber zu ok dann stimmt das doch
boxy pass ok dann dann ist das doch richtig wir des sonntags dann gucken wir noch ran
Dann...
Da gehört so ein Gunicorn, soll es da geben.
Aha.
Das ist jetzt...
Was brauchen denn Socket?
Was brauchen der?
Braucht der irgendwas
Spezielles?
Aber guck mal, der hat Read-Write.
Der hat Read-Write für
alles.
als was krepp das was läuft der engine x als www data also sudo sudo minus www
data minus den bash run unicorn aber darauf zugreifen dürfte ich ja
weil sonst würde ich ja irgendwie das geht also das scheint zu funktionieren
guck mal noch mal in die engine x config
da steht da nämlich noch was drin
Nee.
War Lock Engine X
Error Lock.
No such file or directory
while connecting to upstream.
Moment, heißt das überhaupt so?
Heißt das überhaupt so?
Das heißt nicht so
Das heißt SOC
Alter jetzt, gebaten sie einen ja hardcore
Mit wie schreibt man es richtig
Da musst du gut per Auge
Greppen
Bei den Aufgaben gerade
SOC
System CTL Restart
Engine X
Hello World sollte jetzt da rauskommen, weil das funktioniert.
War Lock Engine X.
Error.
Jetzt gibt es kein Error mehr zumindest.
Bild da nicht ein Slash am Ende der Nginx-Config?
Hä, was, echt?
Meinst du da?
Nee, nee, nee.
Das glaube ich, okay.
Oder wo meinst du?
So, dann installieren wir mal tmux.
Starten das.
Gehen wir mal hier unten nach var log.
tail-f access log, ups, nginx, guck mal in das access log rein, wenn ich da drauf zugreife,
ob da irgendwas tut, curl localhost, 200, funzt, ja, also die nginx seite würde ich sagen, ist ok,
Das Fonds, 200.
Alles gut, ja.
Ist vielleicht an der Python-Anwendung
noch irgendwas, Shep?
Da kommen 0 Bytes.
Ja, vielleicht ist einfach diese Python-Anwendung
verkehrt, falsch, kaputt.
Wo liegt denn das?
Geht das da irgendwo?
Home Admin WSCGI.
Ups.
Dev Applications...
Ist das richtig, wie man das in Python macht?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich sag mal, es sieht richtig aus.
Die Content Length ist 0.
Das hast du gut gesehen.
Da hätte ich jetzt noch 3 Stunden drauf geguckt.
Ja, richtig.
Richtig, richtig.
Du hast recht, ja.
Du hast recht.
Wie macht man das denn dann?
Was ist denn ein... Was ist denn B?
Python B-String.
B used to create a byte literal.
Aha.
Einfach rauslöschen? Setzt der es dann automatisch?
Oder muss ich das ausrechnen?
ausrechnen. Weil sonst hätte ich gesagt wir machen jetzt quasi B, Hello World und dann sagen wir so was wie
die keine ahnung
längst macht man das in parken gescheit set maus gleich
moment kurz preisen stellt starten
okay so
und hier ist okay was das jetzt system ctl ries da und unicorn
service der wird wahrscheinlich auch den den socket neu starten so und jetzt können wir noch mal
Ja.
Ha!
Oh.
Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht.
Mein Python-Stelz hat es kaputt gemacht.
Das war keine gut.
Das war falsch.
Ich habe irgendwelche Fehler produziert.
Okay.
Das fonzt so nicht.
Warum aber eigentlich nicht?
Muss das vielleicht ein String sein?
Kann das sein, dass ich das nicht Strill nennen darf?
Pust Strill, oder?
Oh, mein Python stellt es zu schlecht, Alter.
Ich habe Strühe überschrieben, das ist richtig dumm.
Ich brauche hier Content.
Content.
Und jetzt nochmal Strühe, ne?
So muss man das machen.
content ja kaum macht man es richtig wie start
kaum produziert man keine syntax fehler mehr funktioniert auch
easy
check my solution hat funktioniert weiß next
Lisa Bonn, ETCD, SSL
Leute, nein, keine Zertifikate
Keine Zertifikate, das machen wir jetzt nicht
Das machen wir jetzt nicht
Zertifikate wird geskippt
Keine Zertifikate
Machen wir lieber das
Another Disk Space Scenario
brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Nee, ich mache heute keine Zertifikatssachen.
Zertifikate sind ultra abfuck, das will ich nicht machen.
Wenn ich die Umfrage starte, kommt eh Ja raus.
Ist Z-Server kostenlos? Ja, teilweise.
Die Szenarios, wo Pro dahinter steht, die kosten was.
Der Rest ist kostenlos.
Also du kannst so, würde ich mal sagen, so 60%, 60, ja 60%, kannst du 60, 65% kannst du ohne Account und, also mit Account, aber ohne was bezahlen machen.
Ansonsten, es kostet auch nur, glaube ich, 5 Euro oder so, Pricing im Monat.
Ja, wenn du es einmal machen willst, gibst du 5 Euro aus.
finde ich, in gewisser Weise ist das auch
gerechtfertigt, weil da werden ja
pro User, der
ein Szenario startet, wird ja eine
AWS-VM gestartet.
Die kosten ja auch was.
Ja, meistens
nur ein paar Cent, kleine VM,
kurze Laufzeit, aber
nicht umsonst. Und wenn das viele Leute benutzen, geht das
auch ins Geld.
Ja, und wenn man die mal alle machen will, ist man im Monat ja durch.
Dafür mal 5 Dollar
ausgeben, finde ich, geht voll in Ordnung.
So.
Nicht nur ein Container, ne, es wird immer eine komplette
AWS-VM gestartet.
So, also was ist jetzt
hier das Problem noch einmal?
Es läuft hier ein Programm, Key High.
Ein Go-Programm.
Das GoPro-Programm...
Okay, das ist spannend.
Wir haben hier ein GoPro-Programm,
von dem wir nichts wissen, wenn wir nicht den Source-Code haben
und sonst was.
Guck mal mit S-Trace, was das macht.
Bisschen kleiner.
Wobei, sieht man auch nichts.
was sagt denn strays sagt strays operation not permitted was
ja home admin data new data file no such file oder rektory
New Data File brauchen wir.
Sonst sehe ich jetzt hier
erst einmal nichts.
Okay, also
gibt ein Verzeichnis
Data.
Das gehört
Rout.
Oh ne, Admin.
Aber Rout ist die Group.
Ja gut, Admin, Rout, das ist
letztendlich auch okay.
Nur um es mal auszuschließen, dass das
ein Problem ist.
Okay.
Touch.
Data.
Was brauchen wir?
Ups.
Alter.
New Data File.
Es kackt immer noch ab.
Okay.
S-Trace.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Home, Admin, Data, New Data File.
No such file or directory.
Hä?
Ist doch da.
Was?
Hä? Jetzt ist es da?
Das löscht das Ding!
Das Programm löscht das?
Ach ne, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
user local bin ist nicht da no such file directory
Sudo minus i
Update
Search, wie heißt das?
Hallo Kate
Äh
Was für ein Ding
Wo bekommt man das her?
Aus welchem Package kommt das?
dem jahr install
das kann man ja auch suchen
moment haben es doch das ist einfach durch im richtigen verzeichnis user bin
und wir muss nach user local bin aha user local bin das muss man dahin linken
user bin ok
hier.
Ja, ja.
Hallo, Kate.
Okay.
Immer noch.
S-Trace.
Das sieht jetzt aber doch schon deutlich besser aus.
Das sieht doch jetzt schon deutlich besser aus.
Warum ist das schon wieder weg?
Warum ist, warum ist
New Data File schon wieder weg?
Guck mal, jetzt ging das ohne Fehler alles.
Und jetzt will er was machen?
Def 0?
Moment, hat Probleme mit Def 0?
Operation not permitted.
Was?
Was zum...
Moment, ich muss mir die Aufgaben nochmal durchlesen.
der ist make change das ist so in rheinland success without the leading data fall
warum fakt es war eine schlechte idee darauf zu machen
5 Gig.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Festplatten?
Nö, Größe ist...
Es passt.
Kann das sein, dass die...
Dass der eine Datei erstellen will,
die zu groß ist?
Der will eine Datei erstellen,
aber er hat keinen platz das ist es das ist es okay da gucken wir mal ob es noch
ein device gibt was wir dahin mountain können das ist es auch witzig ist hier
die datei verschwindet da immer blk die haben wir da noch irgendwas dran
fdisk minus l.
Also wir haben hier
8 Gig in 1 Gig.
Was benutzen wir dann hier?
Wir benutzen NVMe 0.
So, wir haben hier noch NVMe
2.1 und NVMe
1.1.
Die mit jeweils
einem Gig.
Soll ich da jetzt ein LVM draus machen?
Ein LVM draus machen unter Einhängen
in der Hoffnung, das reicht?
Das können wir mal probieren.
Also PV, Create
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert
Dev
NVMe
N1
und wie geht das jetzt weiter jetzt als nächstes ist glaube ich vg create ach muss nachgucken
vg create two devices genau volume group name kek kek w grip dann dev nv
stb stc
dvs
ok dann meinetwegen so
vg create dev stb
dev stb dev stc
Exist
Warte mal, jetzt bin ich
Jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt.
Was ist das denn jetzt?
Wir haben
Wir haben hier
Wir haben hier zwei NVM-Es
Aber keine?
Wo kommt das her nochmal?
Routillenux.
Was ich mache,
Zeugs basteln.
Sachen spielen.
Mich bewegen.
Passt doch.
Ich soll jetzt DevMapper gucken.
Da bin ich jetzt total bescheuert.
DevNVM1.
DevNVME2.
VGcreate.
So, jetzt bin ich da.
VG create.
Blub.
Geht doch.
Man darf sich bloß nicht auf das Auto komplett verlassen.
So, jetzt haben wir hier was mit 2 Gig.
So, jetzt VG create.
Äh, LV create meine ich.
LV create.
100% Speicherplatz.
Minus N.
Data.
100%.
100% okay dann wir glauben an den wiki data von club 11 v s jetzt haben wir
auch jetzt haben wir einen raid 0 haben wir jetzt einen raid 0 über 2 nv me ssd
ist mit jeweils einem gig das heißt wir haben jetzt 2 gig platz also machen wir
jetzt hier mkfs ext4 nach dev mapper club data und jetzt mounten wir das mount dev mapper club
data nach home admin data okay gut haben wir hier eine platte mit 2 gig so jetzt
führen wir das noch mal aus home admin
Hi, hi ist cannot be cannot be run as super user
Sie amort 777 home admin data
Ok, jetzt haben wir auch rechte hier drauf
Data Touch 1
geht.
Yeehaw.
Get.
Done. Zack.
So. Ich war jetzt ein bisschen
abgelenkt von der Aufgabe. Hat man verstanden,
was ich gemacht habe? Wenn nicht, erkläre ich es nochmal.
Also das Problem war,
das Go-Programm will eine Datei
anlegen, die größer ist
als 592
MB.
Deswegen fällt das.
So, ich habe jetzt geguckt, was noch für Laufwerke in dem System hängen.
Und dann habe ich gesehen, in dem System gibt es noch zwei NVMe SSDs mit jeweils einem Gigabyte Speicher.
Dann habe ich die genommen, habe die in Raid 0 gepackt, machte aus einem Gig Speicher zwei Gig Speicher
und habe sie dann dort, wo das Go-Programm die Datei erstellen will, hingemountet.
Und jetzt läuft das Go-Programm.
So, und ich kack nur,
ich hab das hier zugemacht.
Jetzt können wir es gar nicht lösen,
aber wir sind fertig.
Die vorherige Challenge soll ich
G-Baden?
Guck mal, die haben wir gefailt.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass wir die gefailt haben.
Wir haben die überhaupt nicht gefailt.
Wir haben die geschafft.
Wir konnten bloß nicht auf Done drücken.
So, die vorige Challenge.
Das da.
War das das hier?
Das sollen wir nochmal checken.
Ob wir das Chebated kriegen.
Ne.
Ne, warte mal. Die vorige Challenge.
Close and open file.
Das da.
Run.
Achso.
Cross Open File.
Und jetzt einfach nicht einloggen und auf Testen drücken, meint ihr.
Schauen wir mal.
Aber der hat bestimmt mitgedacht und startet einmal initial was.
Force Champ.
Alter, jetzt mach mal hin und erstell die VM.
So, also jetzt nix klicken, sondern einfach check mal so...
Haha, Chat! Chat, pfeif het!
High IQ Chat!
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
E-E-E-Easy as fuck.
Okay, das können wir dem auf Twitter nachher schreiben.
Freut sich ja immer über Feedback.
Schreiben wir das ihm nachher auf Twitter.
Wollen wir noch eins machen?
Ich werde langsam müde.
So, was haben wir denn sonst?
Komm, wir suchen uns jetzt mal eins raus, was interessant klingt.
Ja, also.
Fun mit Mr. Jason.
Nein, Französisch machen wir jetzt nichts.
Where is my Web-Server?
Kubernetes-Pod-Crashing hätten wir noch zu bieten.
Between two seas.
Restore mySQL database.
How much do you press?
Prometheus can't scrape web server.
Engine X with Brotli.
Das ist Kompression aus der Schweiz.
Modify SQL 3 Lite.
SQLite 3
Database.
Break ist CSV-File.
Cannot connect to me.
Jumping Frog.
Strange
Script Error.
Kostet das was? Ja.
Das kostet für einen Monat
5 Dollar und in einem Monat bist du fertig.
Und für 5 Dollar ist das komplett okay, finde ich.
Weil der muss für jeden User und jedes Szenario eine AWS-VM bezahlen, der Seitenbetreiber.
Command not found.
Business.
Cag Business.
Was ist denn der Business-Tag?
Cag Cag Business, das machen wir jetzt.
Command not found.
Exist business ach so moment moment moment moment es gibt mittlerweile sogar business only
Ja, okay, das ist fies
Ja, das ist das finde ich nicht gut dass es business only pro user ok aber business only szenarios das finde ich nicht gut
Das finde ich nicht gut
Das ist mir zu stonks.
Ich verstehe ja, die müssen irgendwie gucken,
wie man die Kohle reinkriegt.
Ja, aber trotzdem.
Was ist denn das hier?
Optimize Docker Image.
Ich muss mal wieder in die Wüste.
Das stimmt.
Wenn ich in die Wüste gehe, dann gibt es fett Kohle.
Für alle, die das jetzt absolut nicht gecheckt haben,
ich habe mal ein Genshin Impact Sponsoring gemacht.
Und ich hatte eigentlich einen ganz guten Text für die Werbung.
der natürlich klang aus meinem Mund.
Aber das hat denen nicht gefallen.
Die wollten unbedingt ihre 96 Punkte drinne.
Und dann habe ich mich halt hingesetzt
und habe denen ihr Skript runtergerattert.
Und eines der Sachen, die ich da sagen sollte, ist,
es gibt auch ein neues Wüstengebiet.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste oder irgendwie sowas.
Und dementsprechend klang das dann auch im Video.
Aber das hat ihnen dann gefallen.
Das fanden sie dann toll.
Mein selbst eingesprochener Text,
der natürlich klingt und eigentlich auch ganz gut war,
so vom,
dass es sich nicht zu übertrieben
werbungmäßig anhört,
wollten sie nicht.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Wartet mal.
Gucken, ob wir das finden.
Findet man das nicht?
Ja.
Hier müsste das sein.
Wartet mal.
YouTube! Hallo!
Bitte funktionieren!
YouTube!
Oh, ich hab keinen Sound hier.
Na dann nicht.
Dann machen wir das hier.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und ich...
Ah ja.
Sponsoring.
Das bringt mich auch zum Partner des heutigen Videos. Genshin Impact ist ein Open World Adventure Game mit einer großen Anzahl verschiedener Charaktere im Anime-Style. Genshin Impact ist für PS5, PS4, PC, auch für Mobilgeräte, iOS und Android erhältlich. Die große atmosphärische offene Welt lädt dich ein, tiefer zu erforschen. Eine Welt voller Geheimnisse, in der es sieben Regionen, sieben Götter und wie könnte es anders sein, auch sieben Elemente gibt, die kombiniert werden können, um neue Synergien zu schaffen und noch mehr coole Angriffe auszuführen.
Die geschlossene Karte von Genshin, wenn man nur Mondstadt-Leo-Sumero mitzählt, ist mehr als 5.900 Fußballfelder in der realen Welt.
Das Spiel hat regelmäßige Inhaltsupdates wie den kürzlich veröffentlichten Patch 3.1, der neue aufregende Regionen wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann die geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Regionen in Sumero erkunden.
Und es gibt drei neue Helden im Spiel.
Sino ein 5-Sterne-Elektro, Canons ein 4-Sterne-Hydro, beide recht mächtig und schließlich Nilou ein 5-Sterne-Hydro, recht mächtig mit einem Schwert. Zusätzlich zu den liebevoll gestalteten Anime-Visuals bietet jeder Charakter seine eigene spannende Hintergrundgeschichte und eine möglichst tiefgreifende Interaktion mit der Spielwelt.
Zur Feier des Updates auf Version 3.1 zeigt Genshin Impact die Geschichte der Spieler in Genshin in Offline-Werbung auf der ganzen Welt.
In Deutschland werden die Erinnerungen Spieler im Münchner Hauptbahnhof gezeigt.
Ich empfehle euch also einen Blick darauf zu werfen, wenn ihr in der Nähe seid.
Scannet den QR-Code oder seht ihr meinen Download-Link zum Spiel zum Endless Journey Event in der Beschreibung an.
Wenn du diesen Code im Spiel verwendest...
Die wollen das so! Die wollen das so!
Ich hatte echt ganz gutes Placement aufgenommen.
Ich war schon einmal im Münchner Hauptbahnhof
Ich hatte echt ein ganz gutes
Placement aufgenommen
Was sich auch ziemlich natürlich
Angehört hat, ja
Und da haben die gesagt, ne ne, da sind nicht alle unsere Punkte drin
Nimm doch lieber dieses Skript
Und da habe ich denen ihr Skript halt runtergerattert
Was willst du machen, ne
Ich war wie in einer Wüste
Was ist das denn hier jetzt für eine Aufgabe?
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Node.js Application is located in Torino App Directory.
You can run it directly with bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
You can verify that it works running curl.
There is already Torino Docker image build with Dockerfile.
Weißt du, wie viele Link genutzt haben?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was es
an Geld gab.
Aber das war auf jeden Fall
für runtergeratterter Text
mit fertig hinterlegtem
Spiele-Trailer. Easy Money.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
So ungefähr kann ich es euch sagen.
Ich würde mal sagen,
irgendwas so um 1500 oder sowas.
Irgendwie in dem Dreh.
So ungefähr.
Ich kann es euch nicht mehr genau sagen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Aber irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh wird es gebracht haben.
Und ich meine, für eineinhalb Minuten
Text runterladen, 1500 Euro,
ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Guter Stundenlord.
Easy Money.
Easy Life.
Klar, so Werbung funktioniert.
Was meint ihr denn, warum
Raid Shadow Legends
so erfolgreich ist?
vor allem was die bei der raid werbung immer für ein bullshit erzählen so tolle geschichte
tolle grafik tolles hier und da das ist irgendwie ein super uninspirierte auto bettler
Mit 30 Milliarden
Mobile-Game-Style-Pop-Ups halt
Also was
Das geht nur wegen der Werbung
Wegen sonst wird doch keine Sau
Raid Shadow Legends spielen
Die haben übrigens bei mir auch angefragt
Aber Raid Placement hab ich nie gemacht
Du musst mehr Sellout machen.
Ja, ich glaube auch.
Wird Zeit.
Wird Zeit, dass ich mal wieder Videos mache.
Und dann kann ich Sellout machen.
Nun gut, gucken wir uns doch diese Aufgabe hier nochmal an.
Was sollen wir denn machen?
There is already a docker image built with a docker file, but the resulting image size
is 916 MB.
Das ist schön, das macht Spaß.
Your task is to optimize the docker image size.
Build a new docker image for the Torino application also called Torino Latest but with a size
under 122 MB.
Okay, let's go.
erst einmal ist im ersten mal des os wechseln ja erstmal zu wir wechseln
erstmal zu zu debian slim oder so wir gucken mal mal schauen wahrscheinlich
kann man auch noch dateien exkluden die damit weit wahrscheinlich komplett des
node modules oder sowas mit noch ein kopiert also alpine solange sich
vermeiden lässt war ich kein alpine
war ich nicht okay torino app
Ganz schön, ganz schön.
PEPOFAT.
Also ein Dockerfile.
Ein dicker File, ja.
Yep, Cocker.
Also Package.json, App.js, npm, install.
Okay, also schon mal zwei Sachen.
Wir brauchen ein Multistage-Build.
dass das sinnig ist.
Oder naja, gut, brauchen wir wirklich ein Multistage-Bild?
Nicht wirklich, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall...
Naja, doch.
Kann man das kleiner machen mit einem Multistage-Bild?
Weil da kommt ja kein Binary raus.
Da brauchst du ja trotzdem Node.js installiert,
dass du es laufen lassen kannst.
und die notmodules brauchst du weil ansonsten läuft er die anwendung nicht
multi multi stage bild bringt uns in dem fall höchstwahrscheinlich nichts wir installieren
mal wobei doch eine multi stage bild bringt uns was weil wir brauchen dann nicht diesen ganzen
wir müssen nicht npm und sowas installieren wir brauchen wirklich nur eine node.js runtime also
machen wir doch mal machen wir mal doch einen multistage build also from node 16 work dir
bild ich mache das so wie ich das sonst auch mal das komme ich im kopf durcheinander bild
so cmd brauchen wir erstmal nicht cmd kommt weg und jetzt haben wir hier from debian tricksy slim
s run copy from build oh wie ist da die syntax nochmal docker copy from from ah ja genau from
bild nach
worktier slash app nach im prinzip einfach hier hin bild dahin kopieren
und dann das starten so schauen wir mal ob das stimmt was ich jetzt gebastelt habe
Expose kann übrigens auch noch hier unten hin.
Mal schauen ob das, mal gucken ob das jetzt funzt.
Docker build-t kecke Punkt. Irgendwas habe ich mich bestimmt vertippt.
ok docker image mit jess
aha guck mal es ist nur 80 mb groß jetzt mein image rock rock run minus minus m-1 keckel
okay irgendwas irgendwas habe ich fast so ich habe kein not ist installiert ich kann moment debian
update wir können auch das offizielle note image nehmen wo wir gerade schon dabei sind docker
node.js da gibt es bestimmt ein offizielles ach so das ist ja schon das offizielle aber
gibt es gibt es auch bestimmt auch in slim oder alpine bullseye slim das suchen wir tricksy jetzt
auch tricksy 25 tricksy 25 tricksy slim also not
waschei notfirm aber 25 ist halt ein bisserl krass 25 tricksy das gibt es
wahrscheinlich nicht
Es gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht für 16.
Gibt es 16?
16?
16 minus?
Bullseye?
16?
16 Bullseye können wir nehmen.
16 Bullseye Slim.
Gibt es 16 Trixie?
Ne.
Nehmen wir 16 Bullseye.
Docker Images.
232 MB.
Okay.
Das ist auf jeden Fall
zu pad.
Vielleicht müssen wir doch Alpine nehmen.
Was ist denn wenn man hier Node.js installieren?
Ah, das ist doch nicht groß.
Gucke mal.
Ja, 100 doch.
wird es denn jetzt wenigstens laufen locker run run
ok laufen wird es jetzt also unser docker fall ist prinzip ohne
Come on!
Nein, nicht schon wieder!
Na gut.
Tmux installieren.
Upt install Tmux.
Was? Upt update.
Also unser Image läuft, aber unser Image ist auf jeden Fall noch zu groß.
Also weiter im Text.
CD, Torino Up, Docker, Build.
docker images ok jetzt schauen wir mal wie groß das ganze mit alpine wäre
16 alpine
16 Alpine, gucken wir mal wie groß das Alpine Image wäre, auch wenn ich Alpine nicht mag.
Vielleicht können wir aber auch noch von dem Node.js Bild irgendwas wegschmeißen.
Ach stimmt, 16 Alpine. Du hast recht.
Lull.
Darker Images.
Okay.
Jetzt sind wir drunter.
Ja.
npm run build und nur den dist output mitnehmen.
Dafür kenne ich mich mit Node.js Anwendungen zu wenig aus.
Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn man
sudo apt install npm
already installed.
Was passiert denn, wenn man hier sagt npm install
und dann npm run bild aber wir haben überhaupt keinen kein task file also das bild bild action
gibt es nicht das ist ein nackiger nackiger express anwendungen einzige was mir jetzt noch
einfällt ist es gab doch sowas not self content anwendungen single executable files
single executable applications
was
Hä?
Alter, was?
Wie kompliziert
wollte ich es eigentlich noch machen?
Also wir haben es gelöst, ne?
Wir haben es gelöst.
Aber ich mag
Alpine nicht. Ich würde es gerne mit etwas anderem
hinkriegen noch.
Nexe. Nexe hieß das, glaube ich.
Genau. Ja, Nexe.
GitHub Nexel.
Create a single executable
out of your
Node.js Anwendung. Genau das
habe ich gesucht.
Nexel.
Gibt es nicht.
Wie installiert man das?
Wir fragen mal die AI
mit so Sachen zum
nachforschen ich will eine single exe aus meiner notches anwendung machen
wie am besten
ok im jahr 2006 der beste weg für eine 1 auswahl an die nutzung der integrierten single exe sehr
funktioniert er früher beliebte tools wie pkg inzwischen als veraltgeld der offizielle weg
Node.js. Diese Methode ist
bei Node.js 20 plus stabil
und wird für 2026
empfohlen.
Was habe ich denn für eine
Node-Version hier drauf?
Version.
Minus, minus
Version. 20.
Haha.
Ne, ne, in dem Container
ist 16.
Aber seit
20 plus.
Okay, das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Also wir haben es gelöst, aber noch mal gucken.
Fassen Sie Ihre
Anwendung mit einem Tool wie
Vercell NCC in ein einzelnes JavaScript
zusammen.
Was? Ja, wir haben doch nur eine einzelne
JavaScript-Datei. Ne, das ist glaube ich
zu crazy kompliziert.
Jetzt.
Um es mal aus dem Ärmel zu schütteln.
Das ist halt blöd, dass es Nord nicht eingebaut hat.
Ich probiere das jetzt einfach mal.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal, was die hier schreiben.
Vielleicht, vielleicht findest du das ja.
So, SEA-Config.
Da muss man jetzt natürlich reinschreiben.
Nicht HelloJS, sondern AppJS.
Und dann geht das wie weiter?
Experimental SEA-Config.
Das geht jetzt bestimmt nicht.
road single executable preparation plop aha
jetzt und was ist das jetzt create a copy of the note executable name it according to
Was?
Ich check den gesamten Vorgang nicht, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Sag mal, wie zum...
Die sind doch komplett pipige, Alter.
Das ist aber abartig.
Bann kann das, oder?
So, wir installieren jetzt einfach Bann.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Upt, sudo up, install, bann.
Gibt's nicht.
Bann, install.
Ähm.
Ja alles mal schön hier rein nach Bashköln.
So.
Jetzt das hier.
Fun, Bild.
So.
Jetzt das hier.
Bahnbild.
Main.
JS.
Was?
Ach nee, App.
JS.
App.
easy fertig 101 mb alter aber es von ja immerhin was sagt dann der ldd zu aber so muss es auf
sein ja pj fgc dank für den subband kompens single exe kompress
mini fall
Ganz schön fett, ne?
So viel kleiner ist das jetzt aber nicht.
Kann man das nicht noch komprimieren oder sowas?
Wie hieß denn dieses Ding?
Es gab doch für Linux so ein Programm, wo du...
eine komprimierte
Exe, also ein komprimiertes
Executable draus machen kannst. Wie hieß das denn?
UPX!
UPX, genau, UPX.
UPX.
Okay, ob Strip
bei Node.js Anwendung eine gute Idee ist,
weiß ich nicht.
Er ist bestimmt kaputt danach.
Ist aber nur 1 MB kleiner.
Ersägt mein Text fort!
Was hat man hier noch sonst zu bieten?
Compile.
Compress.
Bim, danke schön für den Sub.
ok opx linux wegen das jetzt noch mal altima genau altima packer
vor exekutiven das habe ich gesucht
wie ging das noch mal
startet du musst es doch irgendwie
ab install opx
By the way, was ist das?
Das ist in einem Bann.
Das ist Bann.
Warum heißt das so komisch?
UPX by CLI.
Genau.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Jetzt wird das gezippt.
Das ist jetzt voll durch die Brust ins Auge, wie ich das mache.
Wir haben es ja schon gelöst mit dem Alpine Image.
Wie groß ist es jetzt?
37 MB. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Was?
Äh.
Kann das sein, dass das nicht funktioniert,
wenn es komprimiert ist?
Ich glaube,
UPX font damit nicht richtig.
In der Chat ist es auch nicht.
Tja.
Ja, dann fällt mir da jetzt nichts mehr ein.
Dann würde ich sagen, bleiben wir doch bei der ersten Lösung, die wir hatten, mit dem Docker-Image.
So, was müssen wir da jetzt noch machen, dass es als okay akzeptiert wird?
Zeit ist bald um.
MonkaS, ja.
Okay, was müssen wir jetzt noch machen?
Muss ich das Torino, muss ich das, by the way, muss ich das Torino nennen?
Ohne, sonst gibt es Ärger.
Bild.
Muss ich das Torino nennen?
Okay, das muss Torino heißen, ne?
Sonst...
Ja.
Okay, Torino.
Create a container.
Okay, also.
docker demux docker ps
da läuft schon irgendwas auf port 3000 docker stopp
Ja, auf.
Stalker, run.
Ähm.
Torino.
Ah, Moment.
Ah, ich kack, Luke.
Stalker, stopp.
muss auch die import brauche ich ja noch vor 3000
minus p 3300
Achso das muss hinters run.
SP 3000 3000.
Ok.
Curl localhost 3000.
Message hello from Torino.
Check my solution.
Bam!
Korrekt!
Zack!
Szenarios.
Hab's geschafft.
Und das haben wir auch geschafft.
schafft nur habe ich aus versehen fenster zugemacht
ja leute das reicht für heute würde ich sagen wenn euch solche streams gefallen da lasst mir
doch jetzt ein follow da sei das nächste mal wieder direkt informiert wenn es losgeht
Reicht heute, ich geh jetzt noch ne Runde rennen.
Ne, kein C++ Video heute.
Ich geh jetzt noch ne Runde rennen.
Wollte ich heute Morgen eigentlich, hatte ich dann aber keinen Bock.
Und jetzt muss ich nochmal.
Rennchamp.
Wo rennst du hin?
Hier einmal am Main lang im Kreis.
Heute mach ich nur die kleine Runde.
Eine kleine Runde sind ungefähr 5,5 Kilometer.
Hier ist kein Schnee.
Hier ist an manchen Stellen noch ein bisschen Eis.
Aber Elchengrenzen.
Aber schön, dass ihr wieder alle da wart, Leute.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut. Bis dann.
See you.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.